it's great to welcome ann newman to the
program today
author and columnist and we are going to
be talking about
vaccines operation warp speed there
there are really so many things to
discuss and so maybe maybe to start
operation warp speed i interviewed a
republican strategist recently
and she very adamantly pointed to
operation warp speed and donald trump as
the reason
why so many vaccines are now available i
asked exactly what trump did
she didn't really have anything to tell
me so let's start there i mean
what exactly did operation warp speed
achieve that wouldn't otherwise have
been achieved what was trump's role in
that
yeah trump set this up um as um instead
of you know opening up the market
to the world and trying to make these uh
formulas accessible to everyone
he kind of made this pool of money that
incentivized
six individual companies we're talking
10 billion dollars
probably up to 18 billion at this point
and these six companies received a huge
amount of money as well as
exclusivity um so they were paid say
190 uh you know 1.95
billion dollars for research yes but
then also an additional amount
for vaccines and
those vaccines that payment was
guaranteed whether the vaccines worked
or not
so what it did was pull a whole bunch of
mines in one place
and dump tons of money into them with
this concept that a free market
um which of course is not free right
that's like the perfect example of a
form of socialism
yeah would it would um accelerate
the development of these vaccines
meanwhile the mrna
research was already being worked on by
the national institutes of health
so like all pharmaceutical innovation
this was grandly subsidized not just
monetarily but also research-wise
by um by federal um entities
now i've i've read i i read things that
are
essentially it seems as though both
can't possibly be true on the one hand
i'm reading
about uh how the pharmaceutical
companies
are not releasing the formula for
manufacturing vaccines so that other
countries could just start producing
them right away rather than waiting on
the supply flow
from the companies that are producing
them now at the same time i read
that for example in 2020 i don't
remember if it was pfizer modern
or both said that they were open
sourcing the recipe if someone wants to
produce it
but it does seem as though there is
significant
infrastructure and fixed costs necessary
to do that where
maybe it's not actually going to get
vaccines to people more quickly
if a new country wants to start
manufacturing what is the truth about
that
yeah it's um it's really hard to parse
because the
ip patent um special manufacturing
categories also there's a category
undisclosed information
like since the reagan era pharmaceutical
companies have employed
um a whole raft of special categories
that are covered
um and set up to protect their profit
basically
um and so even though moderna last fall
i believe it was in october
as you mentioned said sure enough our um
patent is we won't enforce our patent
is what they said yes which uh it was a
great pr play for them
but it basically didn't do anything
because there are these other
layers of intellectual property
enforcement that can be employed
whenever anyone gets involved um and you
know i talked to dean baker for the
article
that i wrote for the baffler and baker
who's an expert on intellectual
property said um you know they
um there are many ways that uh the
government
could make this information available
um so intellectual property is being
used to cover
not just the formula for the recipes but
also these
techniques and manufacturing processes
that really could just be disclosed as
easily as any recipe
i mean there's nothing that prevents
manufacturers
of pharmaceuticals from sharing that
information as well
except that they're getting ridiculously
rich
now as a practical question i'll give
you one situation that's happening in
argentina
where i was born and have a lot of
family argentina is primarily using the
sputnik vaccine which many
love because it's open source and now
argentina has announced that they are
going to start
manufacturing it and uh some of my
uncles are very very happy who who are
loyalists to the current administration
but when i actually look into the
details
the ramp if it's even true right let's
assume it's true that argentina will
start manufacturing this if it's even
true
the ramp up process will take so long
that by the time argentina could be
making any of these sputnik vaccines
argentina won't need them and it will
really be used to take something that's
open source
and sell it to even poorer countries in
south america
to make money in argentina so i'm is
like is is that
good or is the scale-up process
really even possible to do quickly
enough that it wouldn't just make sense
to get an order in for vaccines rather
than look at making them oneself
i'm just thinking out loud here well
like anything else it's
distribution and information right yeah
that's um
what hinders um the the sharing of any
kind of material
and so distribution um access to the
apis or the
um the active pharmaceutical ingredients
ingredients
um the um technology and the materials
um could be better negotiated right
there's no central
power that is making sure that the
countries who need this
technology and these formulas are going
to get them
and that's the real problem i mean there
are a number of organizations that at
the very beginning said all right
this is going to be big and as a globe
we need to work together
to to make sure that everyone has the
same access
that medical ethics is employed in the
distribution
of these very necessary medicines and
obviously bill gates came in um who's
playing
um this unnecessarily large role in
public health health around the globe
with an extraordinary amount of goodwill
and he basically co-opted the system
to make it so that everything was run
through
large pharmaceutical companies um and so
here we are with this
crazy bottleneck i also want to
emphasize that in other countries around
the world there are other issues
i um i don't want to take um
india's uh modi off the table as
a stumbling block people are making bad
decisions all around the world
we also know that um on other continents
including our own there are corrupt
governments and corrupt
politicians um and so i think on the
whole
as a as a globe we were completely
unprepared for what was coming our way
and we never
had a strong voice the united states
never demonstrated any kind of
leadership
and certainly during the trump
administration we were
incredibly isolationist in how our
politics were
discussed and and um and mediate it
um so i think that america first
isolationism
also put us very much behind so it's not
just the fact that these
vaccines are hard to get a hold of
because of patents and and
these layers of ip protection but it's
that also
the um the you know just the the
understanding of we need to work
together to make sure this happens just
isn't there
when it comes to the dramatic increase
in actual vaccinations that has taken
place
over the last uh few few months
was this naturally going to happen no
matter who was president or does the
biden administration
uh uh get credit for what they've what
they've done
i think that's a good question i think
certainly biden coming in removed a lot
of the animosity
um he's been clear with messaging i
think there was so much misinformation
whether that's by design in our current
media landscape or just an
administration that really didn't care
about the rest of the world dying
didn't care about the disparity in the
united states where blacks and people of
color
were unable to access vaccine doses um
so i think definitely it's a change and
tone and tenor mean a lot
um but yeah pharmaceuticals are going to
pharmaceutical and
they are working non-disclosure
contracts with countries around the
world
that's a huge incentive for them not
only have they kind of recouped
their um their reputation with all of
this
they've designed the vaccine um but they
um they're also making bank
when you think oh let's talk about that
a little bit is it that profitable to do
this
and i i again i'm you read so many
things that point in different
directions with pfizer for example
from what i've seen the entire
vaccination program
seems to have affected revenue by about
1.8 percent
now it's such a big company that 1.8 is
a lot of dollars but in terms of
year-over-year changes it doesn't seem
dramatic
so what how should we be thinking of
that as a profit center
we should be thinking long-term because
that's what the farmers are doing
they're they're looking at the fact that
we've got strains coming not only do we
have
you know a huge percentage of the world
that hasn't received a vaccine yet
right um they're thinking when the
crisis is over they can raise the cost
of each dose
to you know the normal 125 150
range instead of the 18 to 34 that
they're getting each dose now
for the possible future variant boosters
for example
but also for the possible variant
boosters not only just getting the
vaccine out to the globe but then
following up and this might be an annual
thing for us just like the flu yeah
right we're not sure
how long we're going to remain have to
remain on this
vaccination schedule but also um
the entire vaccine industry has been
changed by covet 19.
in the past big pharma wasn't very
interested in it because it was
you know low cost a lot of generics were
being used
right um and a quick aside here is that
india manufactures 80
of the drugs that we use in the united
states so when we talk about
manufacturing elsewhere it's not like
big pharma manufactures its own drugs
anyway
right right they farm that out quite
often and secondly
um 70 of the materials for manufacturing
drugs come from
china so the drug supply chain has
already
been precarious for several decades so
um
the vaccine industry never really
appealed to pharma because it wasn't a
big
money maker you know you get your
smallpox vaccine and that's it
they prefer the very expensive drugs
that have to be taken every day
say cancer drugs or rare diseases and
that's where their
big money is and so what operation warp
speed
did was dump a whole bunch of money into
the vaccine industry and make it very
profitable
and bestow a crazy amount of goodwill
on these companies last thing i want to
talk about when we think about the
trajectory
for vaccinating the world and we know
that there are countries that
uh we're talking 2022 we're talking 2023
you know different estimates
one says 2024 until you really have full
vaccination in some parts of the world
ultimately will the bottleneck be
a manufacturing and distribution
bottleneck will it be an intellectual
property bottleneck what is the one
thing that if it changed
could move that date up countries are so
different
our relationships with them are so
different it's really hard to say
but i believe that it's probably going
to be the distribution
and the manufacturing and those special
manufacturing techniques
um and that's just a lack of
coordination
but that's not to say like like
intellectual property law
is kind of the umbrella term for a whole
bunch of things
right so if companies are willing to
share their
drug patents but not willing to share
special manufacturing techniques
it's the same thing they're they're
causing
um other manufacturing entities out
there
from getting up to speed on distributing
this right it would be like if i have a
really complicated souffle
i could give you the list of ingredients
but the technique as to
what i do with the ingredients is
essentially just as important
right exactly uh we've been speaking
with
anne newman author and columnist uh and
i so appreciate your time today to talk
about this really important topic
yeah i agree thank you for covering this
thank you very much